October 01,
change your retirement contribution.
For example,
of part-time workers,
mentions everyone who works
because this may affect you.
What will change?
For everyone who works part-time,
no matter if it is 1 hour,
than 4 hours,
than 3,
than 2 which Sean,
will count you for about 1 full day of contributions.
This was not the case until then,
if someone worked
for example the 4-hour part-time work,
to get a quote 1 day I had to work 2.
Following this example,
that person every day I work even if it takes 4 hours,
will count you as 1 day of trading.
And the million-dollar question,
this is,
i.e.,
it affects past contributions.
Is it not from
of 1 when the quotation starts working?
As we have explained,
what you have accumulated from days contributed in the past
will not be touched.
And this change is very important because for example,
in order to retire you need 15 years of contributions.
In this way,
1 part-time worker will cost you
minus reaching these retirement years.
Follow me because there will be news for sure